I know I asked you this before about
when did you get quote good at acting
but really when did you feel like you
were not mastering the craft but that
you were really honing in and what we
talked about earlier with the Bill Duke
videos falling back into the abyss well
like I said before you know you you
never master you get good or whatever
there's always something to learn and
always take classes always stay in
classes and because of the fact it this
is a work in progress
but what what I feel I think when I felt
like I was really connecting I don't
like to say I really got good I used to
I like to say when I really started
connecting to to what I was doing I
think that's when I finally stopped
trying to be perfect see and you kind of
hurt me that whole thing of perfection
hurt me musically it didn't hurt me as
much as an actor and it hasn't hurt me
as much as an actor but it really hurt
me musically because I got into a thing
as far as singing in musical stuff
trying to be too perfect trying to make
each note sound whatever and that gets
you in your head and once you get into
your head and anything especially this
you're in trouble it's like what Bill
Duke was saying about stage fright
that's dead
that's that ego and everything while you
out you out here judging yourself on
what you're doing it's just the same as
getting it same thing getting in your
head thinking about well um that didn't
sound good or that note could have
sounded better why you performing that's
not good see and and when you when you
drop when you drop that perfection
mindset and accept the fact that you're
not perfect then then you free yourself
to the point now where
you can be the actor or be the character
or whatever you free yourself then
you're able to really have fun and and
let go and explore you free you free
yourself once you free yourself and
anything that's when you get good or
great or whatever the best actors like
he was saying everybody the best actors
are the ones that free themselves to
just be like Meryl Streep Philip Seymour
Hoffman
you know Daniel day-lewis I mean he's so
into that he's this he's this person
that's that's freedom even though he's
so in and locked in he's still free you
know he's free of Daniel day-lewis who's
a nice nice very nice guy and whatnot
you know normally but I mean Daniel
day-lewis wouldn't take a bowling ball
and try to kill something boy with it
pointed at him not Daniel day-lewis but
that character or the person he's being
would and he tried to do that so that's
what to me is when you become good and
when you recognize that is when you
finally accept yourself for who you are
and the fact that you not perfect
because most actors that try to do
everything perfect and just that's bad
because then you're acting and somebody
I forgot who it was said whatever you do
don't ever let them see you act don't
ever let them see that because then
you're in trouble because then people
are looking at you like you know you've
you've seen people perform or act insane
okay that was okay I didn't you didn't
really buy it but the person that you
see like when you see it like Christian
Bale in vice or whatever oh yeah he was
he he was alway in he wasn't trying to
be perfect he was so busy being a flawed
person Dick Cheney is not perfect the
exchange was terrible he's not perfect
so Christian Bale didn't have to didn't
have
try to be perfect okay I mean if we get
religious or something the only the only
person I guess closer to being perfect
was what Jesus Jesus Christ as somebody
you know what I'm saying I mean you know
I'm saying and Jesus Christ if you read
the Bible any of that wasn't perfect
himself you know he had flaws too so you
won't see once you get to the point of
accepting yourself and in saying okay
this is Who I am
I'm gonna just get into this as me and
I'm just gonna let it go and be free and
just let go that's when you got some
beautiful stuff going on
it was great to advise because the
Cheney character the Dick Cheney was
more restrained was sort of this anger
like bubbling at the surface whereas
Lynne Cheney played by Amy Adams was
great and she was emotional and power
driven and it was a great combination
right to see the two of them together
and it was just I left that film
thinking it was gonna be lighter and
more like sort of this like sexy
rock-and-roll version of it and I was it
took me like an hour to feel normal
afterwards whatever normal is well it
was pretty emotional it was it was not a
light movie it was excellent but I
really affected me now the daughter
mm-hmm she's in politics uh-huh okay
she's a combination of the two which is
really scary hmm okay because she has
his dark underside but she has her
mother's emotional side like like Lynne
Cheney was so she's in Congress now and
she's sitting back this sneering and
saying stuff she just got in there she
just got in here now they've elevated
her all the way up in the House of
Representatives to be the top Republican
female there's women been there in the
House on the women on the Republican
side they put her there because they
need somebody to counteract if it was so
they think Nancy Pelosi
so they got his daughter there who has a
sinister Dick Cheney thing but she's out
with it
come others so it's like whoa see I've
heard already say some stuff I'm like
that was crazy
but I mean you know it's just it's just
funny how that is it's just funny and
and and getting back to being an actor
being able to like Bill Duke said it's
like falling into darkness backwards to
do that it's like that whole you know
that experiment if you haven't been in
one of those cycle it's like a actors
where you trust things you know oh yeah
but you know somebody hit you yeah
whatever you know it's like that we're
okay
you gotta let yourself and be honest
with you it's hard to let yourself go
when somebody got to catch you I mean I
don't care how great of an actor you
it's hard to fall back and you got
somebody back here trying to catch you
that you don't know but you don't know
if they got me to catch your big fat ass
like me it's like okay I'm still okay
I'm I can't let go to this you know cuz
I'm scared I'm gonna hit my damn head
but what he said was basically once
you're able to just free fall backwards
then you there you know so so it's it's
a little more work I gotta do you know
you